Transcription: alix poncon
Relecteur: eric vautier
Je suis un éco-anxieux.
En tout cas, je l’étais.
Il y a encore quelques années,
on m’a envoyé en mission
pour planifier l’électrification
de villes et villages
à base d’énergie solaire.
D’une semaine sur l’autre,
on me donnait un billet d’avion
dans une main,
une liste de contacts dans l’autre
et je devais me rendre sur place
et revenir avec une solution.
J’arrivais après un ou deux jours
de route en brousse
dans des villes reculées
et sans service continu d’électricité,
dans des campements de fortune.
Je me souviens d’une ville dans le Sahel,
une ville de 15 000 habitants,
où chaque soir à la tombée de la nuit,
le chef de la centrale électrique
allumait le groupe électrogène
et sous un gros vacarme
de camion qui démarre,
les lampadaires de la rue principale
s’allumaient un à un.
Les rencontres et les apprentissages
étaient toujours extraordinaires.
Avec ces missions à répétition,
je n’avais pas le temps de me poser
et de laisser descendre sur moi
l’éco-anxiété qui m’avait envahi
quand j’étais adolescent.
J’avais plongé
il y a une vingtaine d’années
la tête la première
dans le monde des adultes,
qui m’avait pourtant profondément déçu.
Ces adultes que je voyais courir
après le temps et l’argent
et qui semblaient être devenus insensibles
à la nature et au vivant
qui m’émerveillait enfant.
C’était comme si,
une fois passée l’insouciance de l’enfance
à regarder les papillons,
les escargots, les arbres,
on n’avait plus le droit
de s’y intéresser.
Il fallait passer aux choses sérieuses.
« Deviens ingénieur », on me disait.
« Tu verras, tu gagneras bien ta vie. »
C'était si facile.
Si...
si tentant,
si logique en fait, de suivre la carrière
qui avait été toute tracée pour moi.
Avec cette même logique,
je me dirigeais alors vers une carrière
le plus en accord avec mes convictions.
Je voulais au moins être utile
et protéger l’environnement
avec les énergies renouvelables.
Mais petit à petit,
la quarantaine approchant,
je me sentais de plus en plus déraciné,
déconnecté du milieu où je vivais.
Mes enfants grandissaient et me demandant
des nouvelles de la planète,
je ne pouvais pas les regarder
dans les yeux en disant : « Eh oui,
la planète va mal,
mais qu’est-ce que je peux y faire ?
C’est votre problème maintenant.
Moi, j’ai déjà choisi ma carrière.
C’est trop tard. »
Mais pire que l’éco-anxiété,
était le sentiment d’impuissance
face à l’ampleur du constat.
Quand je sentais cette angoisse,
cette anxiété monter en moi,
j’avais pris l’habitude
d’aller m’immerger en forêt.
Sa patience, sa résilience et sa puissance
avaient toujours provoqué en moi
un profond émerveillement.
Et après, on fait quoi ?
On fait un câlin à un arbre
et on repart travailler ?
Non.
Ce n’était plus suffisant pour moi.
J'ai décidé que cette anxiété serait
le moteur d'un renouveau.
Je voulais construire
et je voulais me reconnecter au vivant.
Plongez dans le concret avec moi
car j’ai tout laissé.
Mon travail d’ingénieur, mon appartement
en centre-ville de Francfort
et je me suis installé
à Lacampagne en Gironde,
avec à peu près la seule conviction
que je devais planter des arbres
et que le reste allait se dessiner
au fur et à mesure.
Suivez-moi.
Comme je partais de zéro en agriculture,
j’ai voulu commencer à me former
en vergers bio-diversifiés.
Alors, on m’a emmené ici.
Croyez-moi,
je n’ai pas voulu en rester là.
C’est par la découverte
des arbres et de la forêt
que mon chemin allait se tracer.
Dans le film Avatar,
Grace, la scientifique,
explique à un moment que les arbres
sont interconnectés par leurs racines
et qu’ils communiquent entre eux.
Vous vous souvenez ?
J’ai découvert grâce aux travaux
de Peter Wohlleben et Suzanne Simard,
que, dans la vraie vie,
non seulement c’est avéré,
mais ça va au-delà.
Les arbres sont interconnectés entre eux
par des réseaux de micro-champignons
dans le sol.
Ils échangent des nutriments
et des informations
sur leur environnement.
À peu près au même moment, je rencontrais
des étudiants en agroforesterie
qui me parlaient d’arbres forestiers
et de production de nourriture.
J'ai découvert l'agriculture
de régénération.
Et plus particulièrement
l’agroforesterie successionnelle.
Ma compréhension du vivant a changé.
Ma vie n'allait plus être la même.
Je suis devenu paysan
avec l’ambition d’améliorer
le milieu dans lequel je cultive.
Mais surtout, pas seul dans mon coin.
Je veux aussi animer, je veux tirer
d’autres personnes de l’éco-anxiété.
Je veux transmettre et je veux montrer
qu’on peut simplement partir de la peur
pour construire.
J’ai créé en 2020 une ferme participative
pour devenir un acteur local
de la transition agroécologique.
Un mois après,
les premiers volontaires arrivaient,
je commençais à construire.
Je vous explique ce que je fais.
Dans ma ferme participative,
on met en œuvre
cette agroforesterie successionnelle.
La définition
la plus simple de l’agroforesterie,
c’est l’utilisation de l’arbre
en agriculture.
Hélas, le plus souvent,
ça se résume à de simples rangées d’arbres
d’une seule espèce,
par exemple des peupliers,
intercalés dans de la monoculture,
typiquement des céréales.
On reste finalement
dans un modèle très conventionnel.
Les interactions et les bénéfices
sont limités
et on continue de dépendre
du travail du sol
et des intrants chimiques, les engrais.
En agroforesterie successionnelle,
on va s’inspirer
des successions naturelles de végétation
qui vont faire évoluer un sol nu
vers une forêt stable,
mature et abondante.
Je vous dresse un tableau,
partons d’un sol nu.
Sur un sol nu,
les adventices, celles qu’on appelle
aussi les mauvaises herbes,
vont rapidement couvrir le sol.
Typiquement, le chiendent.
D’année en année,
une prairie diversifiée va s’installer.
Puis si on continue, alors toujours
sans intervention humaine,
on aura rapidement des ronces.
Les ronces vont permettre l’arrivée
de petits oiseaux, de petits rongeurs
qui, par leur activité,
vont amener des graines.
Ces graines vont permettre l’implantation
des premiers arbres,
les espèces pionnières,
qui vont former des bosquets
et au sein de ces bosquets
vont apparaître les espèces émergentes
jusqu’aux chênes, l’apothéose,
l’emblème même de la forêt tempérée.
On va évoluer en l’espace de 50 à 100 ans
vers les forêts telles
qu’on les connaît aujourd’hui.
Alors tout ça, c’est bien joli,
ça permet certes de régénérer le sol,
mais ça ne produit toujours pas
notre nourriture.
En agroforesterie successionnelle,
on va s’en inspirer
pour produire
de la nourriture sans intrants.
Difficile à croire.
Je m'explique.
Prenez un verger typique de pruniers
où sont disposés les pruniers
tous les six mètres.
On ne peut pas les planter plus serrés
car ils se gêneraient pour pousser.
Par contre, entre,
on peut planter un arbuste plus petit
et plus tolérant à la pénombre.
Prenons un noisetier.
Entre ces arbres, même exercice.
On peut planter un arbuste
encore plus petit et tolérant
encore plus la pénombre,
par exemple un mûrier.
Donc des deux arbres du début
qui étaient de la même espèce,
on va se retrouver à un arbre
tous les 1,50 m,
chacun avec l’accès à l’espace
et à la lumière qui lui convient.
En d’autres termes, on va optimiser
la façon d’utiliser la lumière du soleil
pour produire plus de biomasse.
Avant, on avait nos deux pruniers
et de l’herbe,  qui en plus nous dérange.
Et là, on a nos deux pruniers,
notre noisetier et nos mûriers.
Vous suivez ?
Alors on continue.
Entre ces arbres fruitiers productifs,
on va implanter
des arbres secondaires ou compagnons.
Ces arbres ne vont pas servir
à produire de la nourriture,
mais encore plus de biomasse,
encore plus d’interactions,
et encore plus de diversité.
Un peu à l'image d'une forêt.
Toute la biomasse
que ces arbres vont produire,
on va la restituer sur place
en coupant toutes leurs branches.
Donc des deux espèces de départ,
on va se retrouver à une dizaine d’arbres
sur la même surface avec une production
de biomasse pour notre système.
Alors je vous entends penser :
« Toute cette proximité,
ça va créer de la compétition. »
Eh bien non, on va créer de la coopération
car par la diversité de cet assemblage,
on va créer un sol vivant
au même titre qu’un sol forestier.
Un sol vivant, ce sont les champignons,
les vers de terre, les microbes
et ces fameux mycorhizes :
les associations symbiotiques
entre les racines des arbres
et les champignons,
qui permettent l’échange
de nutriments et d’informations.
Il y aurait dans une poignée de sol sain
et riche en matière organique
autant d’organismes vivants
que tous les humains
qui ont vécu sur la planète.
Ça fait beaucoup de zéros.
Donc pour résumer :
on va produire sur place
notre matière organique,
on va développer la vie du sol,
la vie du sol en digérant
cette matière organique
va disponibiliser les minéraux
pour nourrir nos arbres
et on va nourrir cette vie du sol
par la matière organique
qu’on va apporter tous les ans.
La boucle est bouclée.
On a notre machine à biomasse.
Elle est vivante.
Et son seul intrant est gratuit,
c’est l’énergie du soleil.
Il manque un facteur dans ce système.
Vous me direz, il faut de l'eau
pour que ça fonctionne.
Eh bien, cette densité racinaire
qu’on va créer, elle a d’autres fonctions.
L’exploration des racines
va créer des microfissures
qui vont faciliter l’infiltration
de l’eau de pluie
et l’augmentation du taux
de matières organiques dans le sol
augmente la capacité
de rétention d’eau du sol.
On a un autre moyen, en plus,
de ralentir l’eau de ruissellement
sur un terrain,
on va planter nos rangées d’arbres
perpendiculairement à la pente,
le long des courbes de niveau.
Nos lignes deviennent des courbes.
On crée un paysage
régénératif et comestible.
J’ai planté en 2021,
à l’aide de bénévoles,
2000 arbres sur un hectare,
qu’on a continué d’agrandir cet hiver.
Et on continuera l'hiver prochain.
Et vous voulez la cerise sur le gâteau ?
On va parler du carbone,
un sujet plutôt d’actualité.
Toute cette matière organique
que l’on va créer et stocker dans le sol,
ce n’est que du carbone capté de l’air
par l’effet de la photosynthèse.
Alors que l’agriculture conventionnelle,
elle est émettrice de CO2
et notamment par le travail du sol,
qui libère le CO2 stocké
et qui tue la vie du sol.
Ça fait des réponses
à bien des problèmes d’aujourd’hui
rien qu’en plantant
des arbres différemment.
Maintenant.
Je voulais aller au-delà de juste produire
différemment dans mon coin.
Je voulais aussi reconnecter
le consommateur à ces produits
et l’humain aux vivants et aux saisons.
Trop souvent, j’ai constaté
que le monde agricole
et le monde civil ont chacun l’impression
qu’ils ne peuvent pas se comprendre.
Quand pour la dernière fois avez-vous
participé aux activités d’une ferme ?
Quand avez-vous ramassé des œufs chauds,
sous une poule,
qui viennent d’être pondus ?
Ou même juste cueilli des pommes ?
A la campagne, on construit le lieu
toute l’année
avec des bénévoles
qui sont logés, nourris.
On accueille des étudiants, des personnes
en césure, en reconversion.
Je pense par exemple dernièrement,
sortant d’un burn out,
un directeur financier
d’une multinationale,
qui tous les matins se portait
en toute simplicité volontaire
pour aller donner du grain aux poules
à 7 h du matin dans le brouillard.
Souvent en venant, les gens s’excusent
même de ne pas avoir d’expérience,
ou de ne pas savoir utiliser leurs mains.
Mais ils ne veulent qu’une chose :
apprendre en partageant simplement.
Alors je vous rassure, on n’a pas
tous besoin d’avoir la main verte
ou même l’envie de produire
de la nourriture.
Autant, j’estime qu’être agriculteur
en agroécologie, c’est un acte militant.
Autant le consommateur
est le plus puissant levier
pour mener au changement.
Le plus facile à faire
pour chacun d’entre nous,
c’est simplement de chercher
nos petits producteurs locaux,
car ils sont là.
Ils sont proches des grandes villes.
Trouvez-les, achetez leurs produits,
soutenez-les, parlez d’eux.
Car si acheter leurs produits,
c’est d’abord contribuer
à leur viabilité économique,
c’est aussi, mais surtout,
s’engager pour la souveraineté
alimentaire de son territoire.
Le jour où l’énergie sera trop chère
pour faire pousser
des tomates toute l’année
ou pour transporter des salades
à travers toute l’Europe,
il sera trop tard pour se dire :
« Ils sont nos producteurs locaux ? »
Finalement,
ce qui s’est passé en moi
il y a quelques années,
c’est que j’ai laissé parler
mon enfant intérieur.
J’ai laissé remonter les peurs
que j’avais enfouies au fond de moi.
Je me suis imaginé
assis en face de moi-même,
âgé de sept, huit ans,
moi, l’adulte en train d’essayer
de justifier de mes actes,
le regard fuyant.
Et moi l’enfant en face,
secouant la tête et disant :
« Mais où est passé ton
émerveillement pour le vivant ? »
A partir de ce moment,
j’ai su que je ne pouvais pas
en rester là,
qu’il fallait que je construise
avec cette même peur,
qui sinon me tirait vers le bas.
Il fallait que je trouve ma vraie place
et réalise mon vrai potentiel.
Pas mon potentiel académique
et loin du discours que les adultes
de mon enfance mettaient sur ma route.
Maintenant,
je m’assois face à mon enfant intérieur
en le regardant droit dans les yeux
et je lui dis avec fierté :
« Quand tu seras grand,
tu soigneras la terre. »
Merci.
(Applaudissements)